I've been an iPhone user ever since the
iPhone 6 and I liked it so much that I
upgraded to a new iPhone every single
year up until my current iPhone 11 Pro
max which I love and with the release of
Samsung's Galaxy S 20 ultra I decided to
try it out and see what differences I
would notice so I could give you guys a
good idea of what it'll be like going
from an iPhone to the new S 20 ultra the
first thing I noticed is that the
Samsung feels quite a bit thicker in the
hand but I honestly don't really mind
because I'm used to not using a case on
my phone in terms of the width and
height the 11pro Max is already a pretty
big phone so I can just barely use it
with one hand when I really need to but
the s20 ultra is huge size just pushes
it over the edge so you definitely want
to be using two hands especially if you
don't use a case I'm very thankful that
Samsung finally got rid of that bixby
button because it was honestly useless
to me and I would accidentally hit it
every now and then and now since is gone
you also get a really nice and clean
layout I just wish it had a physical
mute switch like on my iPhone everyone's
also been complaining about the
headphone jack being gone on the s20
line but the iPhone hasn't had it in
years so I obviously don't care the back
of the s20 ultra looks great but I wish
they use matte glass instead of glossy
since I absolutely love the matte glass
on my iPhone since you can't see
fingerprints on it and it actually does
a great job at being scratch resistant
the huge camera bump actually looks
pretty nice but the worst thing about it
is that it's incredibly thick like much
thicker than the bump on the iPhone 11
pro this causes it to wobble quite a bit
when laying flat on a table and it's so
large that my fingers touched the bump
when holding it in landscape mode which
was a bit annoying and it means that you
get extra fingerprints all over the
lenses the display is absolutely massive
and it looks amazing I love the small
hole punch camera compared to the notch
on the iPhone that's honestly getting
really old at this point I also
absolutely love using the 120 Hertz mode
on the s20 ultra since everything feels
super smooth compared to 60 Hertz on my
iPhone it's definitely worth it
even though 1440p looks a bit more
detailed in comparison the gaming
performance was great at 120 fps
with no noticeable performance issues or
framedrops the phone itself felt
impressively cool even after an hour
straight of gameplay and it only used
about 15% battery life after that full
hour I'd honestly say that because of
this massive 6.9 inch display and the
120 FPS support this is hands-down the
best phone for gaming so far it just
sucks at the best mobile games like
fortnight pub G in Call of Duty mobile
don't yet support 120 FPS but I'm sure
that they will soon especially if the
iPhone 12 gets a 120 Hertz display my
iPhone 11 pro max has substantially
better battery life compared to my old
tennis max and I've noticed that even
though the s20 ultra has great battery
life while gaming it was actually worse
overall compared to my iPhone even
though it has a much larger battery in
terms of Internet data speeds we have
sub 6 5g here with t-mobile and in our
office which has pretty terrible LTE
speeds we got a much faster download
speed on the s20 ultra with my 11 pro
max youtube videos would pause to buffer
every now and then but that hasn't
happened yet with the s20 loading videos
and web pages has been incredibly snappy
compared to the LM pro max although my
iphone has the loudest speakers on any
iPhone that I've ever tested the s20
ultra speakers are quite a bit louder
just listen to the sound comparison for
yourself
[Music]
the extra volume is great because there
are honestly days when I wish my iPhone
speakers were louder like when I'm
trying to listen to a podcast so I'm
very happy with the speakers on the s20
ultra and thanks to these awesome
speakers and the huge display this is
probably the best phone out there for
watching Netflix or anything else I also
really love the picture-in-picture mode
which is great if you need to quickly do
something else without having to pause
the video I phones have always felt a
bit faster to me maybe because of the
slightly faster animations or the touch
sensitivity but now that the s20 ultra
has 120 Hertz refresh rate and 240 Hertz
touch sensitivity it feels much faster
and snappier than the iPhone every
single time I also like the fact that it
comes with an SD card slot that supports
up to one terabyte of extra storage
instead of paying hundreds of dollars
more to upgrade the storage on an iPhone
I'm personally a Mac user both here at
the office in at home on my macbook pro
so it really sucks to not have airdrop
which literally makes transferring
photos and files to and from my Mac and
other Apple devices the most convenient
thing ever but thankfully the Android
file transfer app works pretty well when
connecting it using the included USB C
cable it's awesome that the s20 ultra
supports up to 45 watt fast charging but
they only include a 25 watt charger but
that's still faster than the 18 watt
charger you get with the iPhone 11 Pro
and the reverse wireless charging
feature is really cool since most of the
new wireless earbuds coming out today
come with wireless charging this feature
also made it possible for Samsung's to
create an awesome new case that actually
lights up and gives you an exclusive
wallpaper that you can't get anywhere
else I absolutely love face ID on my
iPhone and have always preferred it
compared to the ultrasonic under display
fingerprint sensor that Samsung has been
using but now with the s20 altra I've
noticed that they've really improved the
speed and reliability of this
fingerprint scanner so it's actually not
too bad anymore I absolutely love the
always-on display that tells me all the
info I need to see without having to
turn the display on which is something
that's sorely missing from the iPhone
and as many of you know you get a lot
more options for customization in the
settings with Andrew
which is something you don't get with
iOS so attack heads will definitely
enjoy using the s20 ultra one of the
main features that Samsung really tried
to focus on with this phone is the
cameras and they decided to pack in some
crazy features like the 108 megapixel
main camera the crazy 100x super zoom
telephoto camera in a 40 megapixel
selfie cam so let's talk about it I've
noticed that selfie photos look better
on the s20 than on the iPhone especially
in low light so that's a pretty huge
plus in our blind camera test the s20
ultra did incredibly well for a lot of
the scenarios it only lost by one point
to the iPhone because of the iPhones
incredibly detailed deep fusion feature
and the better night mode photos so
photo quality on the s20 ultra is
actually really impressive especially
considering the fact that we should get
more software improvements soon selfie
video looks pretty good as well but if
you shoot at 4k 60fps it seems to be way
out of focus especially when bringing it
closer to your face which is annoying
since I like to use 4k 60 on my iPhone
you can see what I mean in our video
quality comparison which I'll link to at
the end of this video the same thing for
the rear camera 4k 60 only works with
the main lens not the telephoto or the
ultra wide which also sucks because the
iPhone lets you shoot 4k 60 with
literally any of its lenses the s20
ultra can't shoot 120 FPS slow fees like
the iPhone can but that feature is
honestly a gimmick and I haven't used it
at all since I got it we did try out the
new super hyped up a Kay video recording
mode on the s20 ultra but it currently
has some pretty massive limitations
first off the auto focusing speed and
reliability is absolutely horrible it
suffered from constant focus hunting and
in some cases it wouldn't focus at all
it's also limited to recording at 24 fps
and the exposure gets considerably
darker compared to shooting in 4k not
only that but stabilization goes
completely out the window as well to
make it even worse a key mode only works
on the main lens so if you're going to
be zooming in you actually get quite
more detail by just shooting at 4k
instead so it seems like the a ke mode
is really only useful if you're standing
still not rack focusing between subjects
and when you're in a very bright
environment absolutely do not use it for
low light because as you can see here
the iPhone 11 pros 4k is actually more
detailed than the a K on the s20 ultra
in this medium to low light scene the
good news is that the regular old 4k 60
mode on the s 20 ultra actually works
and looks pretty decent so I'm pretty
happy about that
but it's still a bit behind the iPhone
and the telephoto lens actually does
look really nice if you're shooting 4k
at 30 frames per second giving you a lot
more zoom detail compared to the iPhone
so that's a big plus but in general for
overall camera quality I would honestly
stick with my iPhone 11 Pro max because
you get the extra freedom to shoot 4k 60
using any of the lenses and it honestly
gives you better video quality overall
compared to the s20 ultra the photos on
the iPhone might not turn out the best
every single time especially in bright
environments where I myself chose the
s20 ultras images more often but overall
the iPhone constantly pumps out good
quality images in terms of detail and
accurate white balance so all in all I'm
really impressed with the s20 Ultra
especially for the awesome display but I
honestly still can't give up my iPhone
and it's because of iOS in the Apple
ecosystem everything is interconnected
and it all just works so well together
the s20 ultra isn't perfect but there's
hope that Samsung will fix the issues
with the cameras and future software
updates and if they do it really will
become an excellent phone so I would
honestly recommend it for Android users
as it's the best Android phone I've ever
used but at the $1400 price tag you
might want to consider the S 20 plus or
the regular $1000 S 20 but if you're
currently an iPhone user and you're
trying to choose between the s 20 ultra
and the iPhone 11 Pro max I would
honestly just go with the iPhone if you
guys enjoy this video make sure to tap
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and you should definitely go
and check out our camera comparison
video by clicking right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see
in the next video
[Music]